-Good evening. I'm Seth Meyers.
This is "Late Night."
We hope you're all
doing well tonight
and, now, if you don't mind,
we're going to get to the news.
President Biden delivered
his second
state of the union
address tonight.
Oh, you mean his balloon
assassination victory lap?
[ Laughter ]
[ As Biden ] You know who would
love some inflation?
That spy balloon, bitch.
[ Laughter and applause ]
But seriously, yeah, eggs are
really expensive right now.
[ Laughter ]
That's right, the state
of the union was tonight
and U2's Bono attended
as a guest
of First Lady Dr. Jill Biden.
And I got to say,
I love that she's using
the office of first lady
to tick off her bucket list.
[ Laughter ]
I mean, she was at the Grammys.
She's going to the Super Bowl.
Now, she's hanging out
with Bono.
[ Laughter ]
If Biden gets reelected,
she's going to get
the old gang together
for one last heist.
[ Laughter and applause ]
President Biden posted several
photos yesterday to Instagram.
Not on purpose.
He was trying
[ Laughter ]
to answer his phone and kept
hitting the wrong button.
[ Laughter and applause ]
President Biden tweeted
a picture yesterday
of the first page of his state
of the union address
and I got to say, I'm surprised
how he's kicking things off.
[ Laughter, cheering,
and applause ]
The Pentagon said yesterday that
the military failed to detect
three Chinese spy balloons
over the continental U.S.
during the Trump administration
due to a "awareness gap"
and because, after the eclipse,
Trump wasn't allowed to look
in the sky anymore.
[ Laughter ]
The first public beach is set
to open this summer
in Manhattan,
along the Hudson River,
so, if you see
some beach bodies,
there's a good chance
they washed up there.
[ Laughter ]
"Yellowstone" actor
Kevin Costner
is reportedly considering
leaving the series
to focus on directing
a new film.
Said your dad, "But, you know,
other than that, I'm fine.
[ Laughter ]
Alright, here's your mom."
A dog in Nevada
was recently rescued
after living with a pack
of coyotes for several months.
Fortunately,
the dog is now safe, sound,
and embittered for life.
"I was living the dream!"
[ Laughter ]
And, finally, the FAA yesterday
proposed fining United Airlines
more than $1 million
for skipping safety steps.
Even worse, Spirit put
black electrical tape
over the check engine light.
[ Laughter ]
And that was the monologue,
everybody.
We're off and running.